it took a while but finally progress
since the Miller report said no
collusion we're now seeing the most
vehement anti-trump errs reconsider
their own extremism take Chelsea Handler
for two years she viciously attacked the
Trump family their supporters and anyone
connected was deemed evil it wasn't
normal but she couldn't see it until now
on Bill Maher I had a midlife identity
crisis once Trump won the election
because I had never had my world filled
so feel so unhinged I think and I had to
pay a psychiatrist to listen to me about
Donald Trump for about the first three
weeks and then once we got past that and
we got to the real stuff I realized the
parallel there was my world becoming
unhinged when I was a little girl my
brother died when I was nine years old I
had never related the two but for me as
I can imagine it must have been for so
many people it was a huge emotional
trigger of everything being destabilized
and I realized just how spoiled and
privileged I'd been all my life to
realize they should be this upset in
this out of ten everyday and the outrage
and the anger I just wanted to fight
people you know this is good to be able
to step back and see that your reaction
is less about the world and more about
the stuff that's inside you even better
these admissions seem to be spreading
Molly Hemingway points out that even
Preet Bharara admits he wasn't thinking
fully rationally his shock over 2016
made him consider secretly recording
Trump in those early days these
confessions are not to be mocked but
actually they should be applauded people
are finally admitting their behavior was
in part never about Trump
it was simply trauma I went through
similar stuff but stepping back allows
one to see the top taking politics too
personally clouds your thinking suddenly
everyone is racist or everyone is sexist
and everyone's colluding but for you at
home this is not a problem because the
personal isn't political meaning
politics is just one store in the strip
mall of life so when that store closes
you got other stores to go to family
hobbies the outside world that's life
but a politics is personal then life is
like a game of gem
you pull out politics and it can all
come tumbling down at least people like
Chelsea are putting their lives back
together again we should wish them well
so I think Danish you should be
applauded for her honesty definitely but
because everyone is going through
something yes buddy everyone that you
see they have something going on that's
going to talk about it yeah Mike it will
be yours everybody knows what you're
going through everybody and remember we
say politics is not who you are it might
be what you talk about it might be what
you're interested in but politics is not
who you are right I mean one we have
these political fights all the time but
it's you have other things that you deal
with there you have kids grandkids you
love baseball isn't that the healthy way
to deal with life absolutely yeah I mean
I but I said I wonder if Chelsea Handler
you know she's I don't know that she's
that funny I'll leave that to you to be
the judge but I wonder exactly how
serious she is about all this you know
with the connecting things I do think
that you're right that there are lots of
people who were traumatized by 2016
mm-hmm Jesse you weren't 2024 is gonna
be tough very hard I was I would blame
the media for the Trump derangement
syndrome because they did not prepare
Democrats for the possibility of his
election and then they halted the
healing process by saying he was an
impostor and hacked the election with
the Russians and then the media coverage
everything has been a constitutional
crisis there's been chaos and everything
has been unprecedented but I think
everybody should listen to the president
when he says sit back and enjoy the ride
Katie they're still even people in the
Republican side that are still kind of
like in a weird I think I'm like
Jennifer Rubin has never really fully
recovered yeah it definitely has maybe
she could take some advice from Chelsea
Handler and go it's like I just talked
about her problems but I think sometimes
politics can be personal you know it's
your value system your beliefs but you
have to keep things into perspective and
politics is on everything and you should
go out get off with Twitter enjoy life
and things that are going to be there at
the end of the day for you and it's not
going to be political parties yeah
lottie's Pilates yeah it's like Pilates
at the end of the day I have on Monday
that is not a new t-shirt somebody make
it send it today and at the end of the
I have Pilates oh my god